the disease has already claimed more
victims than Legionnaires disease and
toxic shock syndrome combined this is
the deadliest outbreak of Ebola on
record there are a lot of experts around
the world who do not yet know how
contagious this is how deadly this new
virus is here are the u.s. panic is
increasing around the world about the
pandemic and the disease spreads to
North America the consequences are
multiplying the World Health
Organization has declared a swine flu
pandemic is the world ready for the
cholera
bubonic plague smallpox and influenza
some of the most deadly diseases in
human history and when they spread
across regions of the world an epidemic
becomes a pandemic and it can result in
more deaths than Wars and natural
disasters a good example of that is the
1918 1919 influenza pandemic which took
place just as the First World War was
ending some historians believe that up
to 100 million people died in other
words many more people than died in the
war itself and when a newly identified
coronavirus emerged in China in late
2019 governments reacted like they had
in the past with quarantine and travel
bans or researchers raced to create a
vaccine we tend to think about managing
an epidemic episode like this in terms
of this or public health or science but
in fact what I would argue is that the
root of many of the issues here are some
social cultural political issues
practices how people live working
environments how people travel why they
live in cities
in 1980 some predicted that science
would overcome epidemics that was the
year the World Health Organization
declared one of the biggest killers in
human history was eradicated smallpox in
its 3,000 year existence this one
disease killed an estimated 300 million
people worldwide the global vaccination
program had prevailed and many
virologists at the time were declaring
an end to infectious diseases and that's
a sun shining example right of our great
optimism that human societies could
actually put an end to disease for the
time that smallpox was being eradicated
was precise at the time that other
emerging infectious diseases like Ebola
were coming onto the scene smallpox is
still the only human disease to be
eradicated and more have been popping up
making the jump from animals to humans
when people started to settle and cities
developed about 10,000 years ago our
relationship with animals also changed
and spill overs took place like smallpox
measles tuberculosis and friends etc I'm
originated in animal populations and
obviously that was a very big change
from hunter-gatherers where there wasn't
the possibility diseases to be sustained
in large populations diseases that are
able to live between species like SARS
make it nearly impossible to eradicate
and that's why the plague which exists
in rodents and killed between 75 to 200
million people in Eurasia still exists
to this day they're polar Mars
massage rice are very complicated into
species relations and they exist in
reservoirs in the world those diseases
are very difficult for us to tackle wild
animals
a small piece of the puzzle the last
century saw an industrialization of
livestock making a perfect intermediate
tree for diseases and in 2009 we saw the
h1n1 influenza virus make the jump from
pigs to people the world is now at the
start of the 2009 influenza pandemic the
US Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention estimated that as many as
five hundred and seventy five thousand
people died from h1n1 during the first
year the virus circulated so when you
mass-produce animals and you have an
outbreak it's very easy for the disease
to move very rapidly through the animal
populations and then linked to all of
these as bigger environmental issues
climate change means that diseases that
could exist in some areas moving into
other areas we're seeing mosquito-borne
diseases move into areas where it wasn't
posing a problem
according to the WHL a global
temperature increase of two to three
degrees Celsius would increase the
number of people who are at risk of
malaria by around three to five percent
or several hundred million malaria
already killed four hundred and five
thousand people in 2018 and linked to
all of this is urbanization millions of
people living side by side allowing
diseases to spread rapidly there are
sort of environmental reasons why
diseases happen in certain places but I
think that the fact that you've got mass
cities the fact you've got a lot of
people moving so many helps in the
spread of disease and that's why how
governments respond is more crucial than
ever
critics of the corona virus travel bans
say it only exacerbates the outbreak
shortages become more common people
suffering from non coronavirus related
illnesses have difficulty making at a
hospital and many flee before the
measures are implemented there isn't
sufficient data that shows travel bans
actually do anything to stop the spread
it's interesting the has this corona
virus outbreak is happening we've got an
h5n1
outbreak and poultry farm in China we've
got h1n1 in Taiwan there are many other
diseases around and they could post
problems we've had African swine fever
decimating feed population 300 million
pigs have died so I think there's an
issue about what diseases gets focused
on why it gets focused on what the
politics of that is what's clear is in
order to tackle infectious diseases a
more integrated approach that considers
all of the variables is needed over the
last 10 15 years has been a move toward
one health which is an integrated health
the desensitize to put human health and
animal health together to say they're
actually we can't deal with human health
and s we integrate and think about
what's happening in animal populations I
think we need to go further in a much
more integrated approach that draws on
insights about how you know human
behavior determines disease dynamics
unless we understand these cultural
social processes I think we're not going
to be in a very strong position in the
future to tackle outbreaks understanding
that new outbreaks are a complex issue
that depends on more than just vaccines
and sanitation that they're inter woven
in the way we live and consume is
perhaps the first step in tackling
pandemics
[Music]
you
you